represent
[Music]
tutor
Rudy Melvin
foro re for
pro Brian would you pass these out in
side did you take one and pass it
down I filled up his Green Sheet the
other day I didn't know what it was but
I guess
correctly we give it to him this
time representative seaworth we're going
to get started representative ler lir
would you please lead us in the Pledge
of
Allegiance
Pledge
we have some individuals filling in for
us today representative Hagen Phillips
representative Lane welcome to the labor
committee representative Melvin
representative Reed and representative
tutor thank you very much for agreeing
to fill
in I'm opening the uh executive session
on House Bill 232
FN and I'm going to recognize represent
resentative Sullivan oh we should
probably let everyone come back in for a
second
here I'm going need that yeah I'm sorry
per this figure I'm gonna have to fill a
bunch of these I don't
know all right representative
Sullivan I would like to move uh
Amendment uh 2023
H it is the amendment that I distributed
to the uh committee via email
yesterday motion is made made is it
seconded seconded by representative
Susi motion has been made in seconded
represent Sullivan you recognized to
speak to your motion thank you um it's
been a long haul
um and um essentially the difference
between this amendment and the amendment
we were looking at last week is um in
the um uh
in the first section section one and
it's the buold print
um it the bull print reads employers
shall provide employees a level of
protection that is at least as effective
as a level of protection set forth in
rules adopted pursuing to RSA
27716 um this means that at no time will
um public sector employers and employees
be um responsible for safety standards
that are anything other than what is in
the Department of Labor rules um
so as the department goes through the
exercise of U adopting new rules to uh
be at least effective as the OSHA
standards in the meantime all of the uh
uh public sector will continue to
operate under the current um safety
standards and so it'll be a gradual over
period of three years there would be a
gradual um uh replacement and shift from
uh the current safety standards to
standards that are at least as effective
as the OSHA standards so um this uh
corrected a potential problem where we
we feared that maybe people would think
they were um responsible for the OSHA
standard starting in 60 days that was
not the intent and I think now the
language makes it very clear that the um
it'll be a rolling adoption over the
course of uh 3 years and it'll be
between the Department of Labor and Jael
car to uh gradually make that shift and
at the end of three years we will have a
set of um uh standards that is at least
as effective as OSHA
19 um so that's uh what this new
Amendment does the rest of these um
components are exactly the same as they
were last week um I'm going to forego
going through that whole thing again I'd
be happy to answer questions if people
have them but uh I I I think it was just
a week ago we went through the whole
thing so I'm going to avoid the um
repetition thank
you seeing no other hands I do support
the amendment the amendment was brought
to our attention by individuals from the
uh Association of counties and it was a
very good point uh this makes uh the
bill better uh it explains it better um
and I would ask the members to support
the
amendment seeing no other hands Madam
clerk would you please call the role if
you're in favor of the amendment you
will vote Yes against the amendment vote
no Vice chair seaworth yes re
Melvin yes re
Reed
yes rep
love yes rep Boyd yes rep
tutor
yes rep kcom yes rep drgo yes rep Greer
yes ranking de Sullivan yes rep hen
Phillips
yes rep Cahill yes rep
Lane yes rep
Susi rep Bard yes rep McKenzie yes the
clerk votes
yes I just I wrote them in the wrong
order sorry um rep Clair yes rep St yes
and Mr chair
yes 10 to 10
representative
Sullivan what no no no no no no no it's
20 nothing 20 nothing oh my gosh that's
why okay
sorry 20 to
nothing I don't know
what
unfortunately it's nice when we all
agree Mr
chair it's rare
representan I would like to move a to
pass as amended motion on the floor is
ought to pass as amended as a second and
by representative
Susi recognize to speak to your motion
um I think it's as I said it's been a
long time coming essentially we have uh
a set of uh department of labor
standards that um have gone long
neglected um it was acknowledged by
former uh deputies um commissioner Ogden
that um the U it' Been at least 10 years
since these have been updated um when
the department did a detailed comparison
between the do standards and the ocean
1910 standards it was very clear that
they were gaping holes in the current
standards and um there are certain
aspects that
uh um desperately needed to be filled in
so um this bill does fill that in as I
said a few minutes ago it fills them in
gradually over the course of three years
that
um process that uh implementation um
method was recommended by the Department
of Labor um and I thank them for their
assistance with this because what what I
asked for is an implementation that
would work for the department and work
for employers and I believe that is what
um has been accomplished here so um
I urge uh the committee to support the U
um ought to pass as amended motion Thank
You by a bunch
today I am OSHA 10 certified I do
believe in safety unfortunately I've
told some of you that in my job as an
insurance agent I've had three deaths on
construction sites that I was involved
with with as an insurance agent for so
when this was brought to my attention I
was very eager to get involved and um
sat down with um representative Sullivan
and then the committee
and probably other than one other
bill for workers compensation 10 years
ago is probably the most
thorough
um analysis of the entire situation that
I've probably gone through on any
particular bill here in the in the labor
committee I think that what was agreed
to by the
subcommittee um which was unanimous
Republicans and Democrats is what's in
front of you um was a probably the best
effort yet to try to get something done
what is bothering me um is the the
quiet say rephrase my words
um
[Music]
the sorry I'm thinking
here the way that I'm I'm being told by
folks that this bill doesn't have a
chance it's not going to pass as is
Municipal Association is against the
bill uh my own um Department of Public
Works in Manchester um has said to me
why is the legislature getting involved
with this it doesn't belong with the
legislature belongs with the Department
of Labor
I had a senator call me and said whatat
are you doing go whatever you do we're
going to kill it in the Senate so I
don't like passing legislation that I
know is not going to
pass
um so what are the options available
well we can go back to study I don't
think that's the right thing to
do
um so I'm betwix and between I have
uh my city officer telling me he doesn't
want it
um associations that I know are going to
be against it so
um I don't like any of
them and it's a little disheartening for
the amount of time and
effort that has been put into this and I
I
uh need
to applaud representative selin for the
the time he has put
in but I think we need door number three
and I don't know that I have a door War
number three
um
so I am not going to support the final
bill and I'm going to support another
future Amendment and I'm
hoping that the silence quietness of
telling me this is not going to pass
that people come up with what they want
what is going to pass I mean we've been
doing this for six or seven months
um I would have liked it to have been
out on the table as to what it should
be um maybe that is the department going
back and and doing what they've done for
I don't know 50 plus years and
revamping
their um safety manual something closer
uh to what we need
um it's it's difficult you know some
will say well
it's the repres it's the
representative's obligation It's A
legislature to push it through and then
the Departments have to deal with
whatever we push through to
them um yeah that's one way of
legislating um but um this is too
big um not to have everyone on board so
with massive regret I will not be
supporting the bill uh and hopes that
between now and the time that this hits
the floor someone has a better idea or
some of the people that are going to not
support it come up with a a way to
support
it
um so that is my two
cents any other
comments
McKenzie um Mr chair I have been
involved in uh workers compensation for
better in 40 years I've sat in a number
of commissions I've been in the in the
room when deals were negotiated for
workers compensation over the course of
many years and I can tell you uh with
fair amount of
confidence that the question of this
Safety Committee was a deal that was cut
between the business and industry and
all the groups as part of a deal to
lower workers compensation rates in the
state of New
Hampshire where we were when we started
through this process in the early 90s
and I've asked you and you agreed to get
Christine grant our research at take a
look at this where we were was there was
nobody who would write workers
compensation in the state of New
Hampshire there was one carrier as you
remember there are 28
now the difference between where we were
then and where we are now is that there
were significant changes made as part of
a
deal and part of that deal was workers
lost things lost benefits and part of
the tradeoff for losing those benefits
and and I can when this research comes
out we can put this on the table and
you'll understand but let me give you
just one example what work has lost they
went from 66 and 23 to 60% of their pay
now it's the municipal Association or
the County Association is not raising
that but that was a significant
reduction in cost to
employers the Qui pro quo for those
kinds of things was to give us a solid
safety and health program so we're not
negotiate we're not talking about a new
program that's coming up we're simply
talking about updating the standards for
the program that was already already we
already agreed to many many years ago
and let me say this and you look at the
at the incidence of workers compensation
in New Hampshire Mr chairman you're
closer to this than I am what you've
seen as a mock reduction in the number
of injuries in workplaces and that's a
result of this program
the safety and health program so all
we're talking about is taking a standard
that it's old and tired and simply
upgrading the standard and that's what
this is that's what this is about now
for people to push back and say and I'm
not sure exactly what the objection is
of the Minal Association but if it's
about money then there's two sides of
the equation there's two sides of that
one side is what we gave up and one side
is what they saved and you've got to
take when you look at the cost of
workers compensation you have to take
both of those into consideration and
this system is it's a reasonable system
it is save people money it's in a place
where we have 28 carriers in New
Hampshire from going from one to 28 so
this has worked and worked well and so I
hope when we take this this vote and we
take this take this into
consideration that everybody gave up
something to get to where we are today
and all we're asking for is simply
update the standard like they do for the
electrical code like they do for the
plumbus code like they do for other
organizations in the state of that's all
we're asking for this is not we're not
asking to startop this all over again
this is already in the law so Mr
chairman I hope that when we go through
this and we think about this that we
really takeing consideration how we got
to this place and the deals that we made
to get to this place and make sure that
public sector workers have a solid
program that that will protect them as
they do in the private sector protect
them as they do in the private sector
and not have two people working side by
side one covered by ocean one covered by
a weak law that's 20 years old thank you
Mr
chairman thank you very much
representative appreciate your
comments any other comments
representative
representative Madam
chair thank you Mr
chair I call you madam chair you did and
I don't mind Madam Clerk
I I just wanted to say
that um representative Sullivan and I
have worked with um an organization that
is um looking at employee rights and
protections in worker safety and know
the story of at least one person who
died because um one of our towns decided
to save money in a really dumb way and
this gentleman lost his life so to
exempt public employees from OSHA
allows
um has has opened the door unfortunately
for
situations where for lack of a better
word
inept managers middle managers have made
choices of money over safety and it
would not have saved that much money
to have saved that gentleman's life to
do a safer way of
transporting um this equipment that
needed to be transported twice a year I
I'm certain this isn't the only incident
where a town or city has tried to save
money or the state has tried to save
money and instead it's at the expense of
worker safety and I think this is just
an a simple issue of
fairness and I believe our public
employees deserve at a
minimum um the basic right to have the
same safety laws that our public sector
already has and I think they should that
it does ensure that
um bad decisions of to to compromise
safety won't be made and therefore I
support the
bill represent
drao thank you Mr
chair on paper it seems like a really
good idea this bill the way it's ritten
because right now we have two sets of
rules good for thee not for me as a
private sector employee my employees are
held to a different standard than public
sector so part of it says you need to do
that but we don't and um and I think we
can all agree that safety is should be
the concern for everybody it doesn't
matter what your who your employer is
everybody should kind of be held to the
same standard the problem and I don't
know how we fix this but the problem
really is the amount that it costs each
municipality and uh and our constitution
says you cannot mandate expand a program
provide a new law without having to fund
it on a municipality so therefore we're
voting on something that is
unconstitutional and no matter how I
feel about it because I do care about
the employees and I want everybody to be
safe and have the same playing field if
it's against the Constitution I just I
can't support the Bill thank
you
Sullivan with regard to the unfunded
mandate um as I understand it the courts
have been pretty clear about this that
if we were
creating safety standards for the first
time ever um that could be considered an
unfunded mandate but because there are
there is a program of um public sector
safety through the Department of Labor
we are not creating something entirely
new and therefore it is not a
unconstitutional U bill it uh simply
makes adjustments the department can
make adjustments to the rules as it is
now um the department has always worked
with um uh public sector employers um
around budget issues where if there's a
violation of the safety standards um
they they've simply said we're going to
have to fix this and I we understand
you've you may need to deal with it
through your budgeting process so we
will have an interim fix and a permanent
fix that will come once you can U deal
with the budgeting but this has been
going on for uh for decades so it's
um um maintaining safety does cost there
have been many um studies done by OSHA
to show that improving safety saves
money in the long term it dramatically
saves money so we are not just saving
injuries saving lives we're also in the
long run saving money for the public
sector in New Hampshire thank
you representative seaworth thank you Mr
chairman um a number of times as we've
worked on this bill we've gotten wound
up on this issue of the of 28a and and
unfunded mandate
um and how a court might rule if it came
before them I've started trying to think
about this a little more simply on after
I got home last week uh after our
committee I had waiting for me the tax
bill for this year's property
taxes and um it was up a decent bit and
when I looked on Facebook there was a
lot of angry people in the town about uh
why the taxes were raised
and um to me maybe that's a simpler way
of looking at at it what is going to be
this impact the impact of this on my
taxes what's it going to be on the
people who voted for me on their taxes
and part of the answer is I'm not sure
um as represent representative suvin
just pointed out there may be uh some
benefits as well as cost
um depending on how this is implemented
it could have more or less of an impact
on the towns on the county whose budget
I'm also responsible for
um but we don't know this is a a request
well we'll throw it out there and we'll
see what comes out and and we'll deal
with it when it does and I'm as the
chairman pointed out I'm un comfortable
with that I've
heard the voices that maybe didn't come
before the subcommittee but are out
there that are are concerned with that
and so for that reason although I voted
for the amendment I'm going to be unable
to support the
otpa and I've
also because I also feel like I don't
want to um discard the hard work that
the department has done that this
committee has done um in speaking with
the chairman
I've come up with what might be a door
number three and if this otpa does not
succeed then I'll offer a further
Amendment thank
you representative
kill thank you Mr chair um I know our
taxes went up too and it's not because
of this because this hasn't even
happened we just have taxes going up
because the state doesn't pay for things
that maybe it should like
education but when we think about safety
and how we how our own our own uh
workers comp rates you know have gone
down year after year because we've
improved safety and our labor department
wants to improve safety it's kind of
stunning that the Public Works people in
in Manchester I don't know about I
haven't talked to night Public Works guy
but I think he'd like to improve safety
rather than uh so don't bother me with
this legisl
so uh I think we should pass the bill
and I hope that people can be persuaded
to support it when it gets to the other
body uh because as we continue to have U
life you know life-changing injuries or
deaths it's it costs somebody and it
more it's more than our tax bill thank
you Mr
chair repr
love thank you Mr chair um as someone
who has had uh you know a life-changing
injury in work um you know the work of
safety is uh is uh pretty Dar important
to me and uh it' certainly get my vote
if this was a budget year you know where
we could make a provision in the budget
to pay for all this and uh you know
everything it go through smooth but
unfortunately it's not a budget year uh
I'd be glad to to support this next year
um but um this year I can't because uh
you know it's a it's an
unconstitutional mandate on on our
cities towns and
counties representative k Mr chair if I
may reply to representative love uh this
is something the labor department will
work over on a period of years so
certainly we're going to have a budget
year or two before much of this is has
taken effect so um I think it's worth
doing
seeing no other hands as a motion on the
floor it's been seconded we've had
discussion if you're in favor of the
motion ought to pass with Amendment
you'll be voting yes if you're against
you'll be voting no Madam clerk please
call the
role Vice chair seaworth no Brett melin
no rep Reed no rep love no rep Boyd no
rep
tutor
no rep kcom no rep Drago no rep Granger
no ranking D Sullivan
yes rep hakin Phillips yes rep Cahill
yes rep Lane yes rep Susi yes rep Bard
yes rep McKenzie yes the clerk votes yes
rep lir
yes rep stab yes Mr chair
no now 10 to
10 bill is up for few further motions
representative seaworth thank you Mr
chairman I would like to move Amendment
49h
and that was distributed at uh last
week motion has been made we have a
second representative culcom second the
motion representative seaworth your
recognized to speak to your motion uh
thank you Mr
chairman some of what we heard uh in the
arguments supporting this bill is that
um the Department of Labor already
regulates safety that we simply want
them to upgrade the standard we've heard
how uh how it's worked how it's worked
well um that the the the costs and the
safety in incidents have gone down year
after year um something the chairman U
mentioned to me offline is that our
municipalities have a better safety
record than Private Industry uh when you
when when you look at the rates
um so what I tried to do here is come up
with an amendment that recognizes all
those facts and does exactly that ask
the Department of Labor to work within
their existing Authority and simply
upgrade the
standard thank you Mr
chairman
Elan I appreciate the sentiment of the
amendment um it however provides no
guidance whatsoever to the department as
to how to go about upgrading its uh
safety standards um the department has
been left to its own devices for years
now and without any guidance from the
legislature has not upgraded its safety
standards um so I would suggest that
simply saying we're going to give you
three positions and and a little bit of
money to uh take out of uh the funds
that the department has available um it
doesn't give them any guidance as to how
to go about um uh changing the standards
so um I don't see that this would
make much if any improvement over our
current situation thank
you
just a committee works very well with
the Department of Labor and Department
of Employment Securities and uh probably
better uh or
or I don't say better than any other
Committee in in the Departments but we
work very well together with them and I
do have a trust in them and and quite
frankly maybe they have to dig deep and
and bring in another person and bring in
a safety uh person and look at the other
States and what they're doing and and
upgrade it without question I will agree
with you 100% my colleagues on the left
side of
me
um that we need to upgrade the safety um
you asked me representative kale you
made a comment about
Manchester um yes uh Mr Clardy uh from
the Department of Public Works um does
not like the
legislature getting involved and and was
very much in favor of of the department
doing something Manchester is very lucky
they do have a safety officer who
manages all this and their workers comp
claims are down 45% from three years ago
because they got rid of the they they
now have the trash barrels picked up
with a
machine um repr wasent McKenzie talked
about the reduction in in claims and and
the workers comp rates going down down a
lot of it has to do with man New
Hampshire's use of
Technology uh to do things uh using
machines versus people's backs and and
other things um I did look at uh the
reports representative kcom had asked um
the department
for review of claims and I and I looked
at where a lot of the claims were coming
from and there bumps and bruises there
are uh back injuries back strains
shoulder
strains um and a lot of these things
um
um so this a very easy place to kind of
pinpoint some of the things that need to
be
done I had requested that representative
seaworth come up with some kind of an
amendment because I do not want this
to this issue to
die um it needs to be upgraded it needs
to be done
um and I'd rather have some available
mechanism um so it doesn't
um so it doesn't die so depending on
whatever happens in the
house if someone decides to go to the
Senate to try to deep six it um there's
another mechanism already available that
came out of at least even if it was a TI
1010 in the committee there is at least
another mechanism available um as a as
some kind of a compromise um because I
don't have any other me me ISM that I
could think of other than another study
committee which I don't want to
do um I think we've done
it um and that is the purpose and that
is why I requested that uh
representative seaworth come up with
something that I I could
support
um that is my
position seeing no other hands oh was
okay go ahead I'm sorry just another
comment thank you Mr CH I want to go in
in addition to our working so well with
the agencies in our perview I just
wanted to add for the benefit of Our
Guest that labor is the best Committee
in the
house because guys like you with a lot
of institutional knowledge continue to
come back
here so um see no other comments no
other hands appreciate everyone's uh
comments and uh respectfulness toward
each
other uh if you are in favor of the
amendment you
will uh vote Yes against you vote no
Madam clerk will please call the
role Vice chair seaworth
yes rep Melvin yes rep Reed yes rep love
yes rep Boyd yes rep tutter yes rep kcom
yes rep drgo yes rep Granger yes ranking
D Sullivan
no rep hen Phillips no rep kahill no rep
Lane no rep Susi no rep Bard no rep
McKenzie no and the clerk votes no
repair no rep stub no Mr chair yes 10 to
so I'll need a u a
report from uh both
parties
on and at this
point you want me to do it yes
please is there any additional business
to come in front of this
committee um on a on a
um we um as I stated in the last meeting
we do have uh anywhere between 10 and 12
bills coming to us I attended to be
scheduled 18th and 25th of of
January uh representative McKenzie
representative kahill I know you have
bills coming in front of the committee
um whenever you have them or whether you
get them or they're signed off or you
have the wording please pass them along
so I can pass them to the committee um
I'm going to try to get a the bills to
the committee as fast as as quickly as
we can it may be a little late but I
don't want to cram us into our you
know end of January where we're meeting
twice I only like to meet once a week if
if and trying to get all of our bills
done in three at least heard within
three
days rep stab has some good bills coming
too a new very well I wasn't aware but
thank you all right thank you very much
folks executive session is uh adjourned